worldwide one in eight women will be
diagnosed with breast cancer throughout
their lives but when you catch it early
you have a 95 percent survival rate and
we're helping women by giving them a
tool that they can use to maybe catch
cancer at early stages my name is Julian
Reyes and I am the CEO of ever when EV I
started I was 16 my is a technology
company and we are developing the
brought that census breast health I
created them a three and a half years
ago it came out of a very personal issue
my mom was diagnosed two times with
breast cancer at first when I was five
years old she was getting the best
treatment and the best screening she
could ever have and despite that she had
a late diagnosis cancer is a very scary
disease at that moment I decided to to
focus all my efforts and understanding
breast cancer women below the age of 40
are completely neglected from breast
cancer screening guidelines join women
cannot have mammograms because of the
radiation exposure so you guys feeling
that particular gap by being a device
that can be used at home and emit no
radiation this is the latest prototype
texture-wise of our device Eva is used
as any type of bra you put it on you
wait for five minutes inside it you have
sensors that map the surface temperature
of the breast after that you take it off
and the data is sent to the cloud and if
we see an abnormal hot spot Oracle spot
in the breast or machine learning and
artificial intelligence algorithms can
differentiate between a healthy patient
and a woman with high probability of
having cancer 20% of the woman we screen
in our clinic have a positive result
which means there's abnormality in the
press
we are using technology to save lives by
empowering women for the first time in
history to have ownership of their
breast held in their hands
my mom is free of cancer right now but
she continues to have health issues due
to the the aggressive treatment she got
when first diagnosed we want to make
sure that no other woman suffers what
some of our loved ones have suffered and
that is a few love this company to make
sure that that does not happen again
[Music]